[Musique]
le film que je recommande est le long
métrage la piscine de Jacques doré qui
met en scène le couple mythique Romy
Schneider et Alain Delon c'est deux
personnages se retrouvent sur une scène
très particulière autour d'une piscine
maintenant
[Musique]
dans la commune de Ramatuelle nous
sommes à la fin des années 60 et on se
rend très rapidement compte que ce petit
épisode de vacances va vite tourner
court et prendre un nouvel élan beaucoup
plus dramatique inspecteur l'évêque de
Marseille
[Musique]
à chaque accident c'est la même chose ce
que j'aime beaucoup dans la piscine
c'est avant tout le couple mythique Romy
Schneider et Alain Delon qui se
retrouvent artistiquement et aussi
finalement cette période très marquée
par mai 68 on le retrouve vraiment dans
le scénario avec des références à cette
génération qui a été très marquée par
l'émancipation de la femme et
l'émancipation même en général on est
juste après l'arrivée de la
contraception en France
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et c'est bien sûr aussi la lumière
extraordinaire autour de cette piscine
dans il faut dire la magnifique commune
de Ramatuelle les décors sont finalement
très naturels et parlent de même et
c'est devenu ainsi la piscine est
devenue un véritable mythe du cinéma
français qui est très apprécié à
l'international et que et que j'aime
revisiter aussi régulièrement
[Musique]